[Music]
it's fourth of july we'll find many
americans at the grill are headed to the
beach it's a chance to catch our breath
as a country after two really intense
weeks of news major supreme court
decisions and historic votes in congress
have highlighted our political divisions
but maybe they've also provided one of
the most vivid examples of how the
american system is designed to work
the constitution lays out three coequal
branches of government one to make the
laws another to sign them command the
military and conduct foreign policy and
the last to determine what laws are
constitutional we're marking
40 years since spain joined nato in the
past week the president has performed
his duty as the leader of america's
affairs overseas we are ready to face
the threats of russian aggression
because quite frankly there's no choice
but there's little a president alone can
do to bring down prices change laws or
protect individual rights we are
fighting for women's rights
this president a former senator knows
better than most that congress is
necessary to achieve broader change the
motion is adopted that's what made
passage of bipartisan gun legislation so
remarkable the motion to concur with an
amendment is agreed to
lawmakers who often can't agree on basic
facts rallied together to finally do
something about mass shootings i think
it's a significant step in the right
direction it's not everything a majority
of americans want but supporters believe
it helps address a growing concern what
are we here for
if not to do something
something meaningful something real
something together
to end this carnage as congress made new
laws it's also used its oversight powers
to investigate events surrounding the
deadly january 6th attack we were
watching
the capitol building get defaced over a
lie the details disturb and infuriate us
for different reasons but don't forget
few other systems of government allow
for such a public examination
across from the capitol nine supreme
court justices have rendered judgment on
several of the country's most
controversial matters the justices ruled
six to three that a gun law in new york
state violates the second amendment roe
versus wade is history the supreme court
sided with religious freedom the
decisions once again divide us and
revive questions about the role of the
judiciary but they're a vivid reminder
that change in america takes
time it took more than 25 years for
congress to pass new gun laws amid years
of patient often painful activism by
survivors and victims
too
many
children are dying and americans opposed
to federal abortion protections have
spent five decades fighting to end them
it reminds this reporter of something
actor michael douglas said in the
american president america isn't easy
america is advanced citizenship you've
got to want it bad if you like even some
of the change made in recent days maybe
it's the result of your own activism and
resolve
if you're upset by what's happening well
america is advanced citizenship
you can get up
and go do something about it
[Music]
ed i mean you know it's i that should be
required viewing in schools
just you know because it reminds us
there's a great quote by wendell wilkie
i believe in america because we have
great dreams and here we have the
opportunity to make those dreams come
true that is the united states of
america i think it is such a good
reminder about the importance of
activism because i think there's sort of
this passive activism that happens now
where you sort of click on something or
share a meme and you feel like you've
done something donate five dollars yeah
yes but you know activism that has
really resulted in significant change
means going to the streets talking to
your lawmakers and voting
and it takes time i think that was to me
that was the biggest thing it was like
look it's taken 25 years for a new gun
law the you know the anti-abortion
rights or pro-life movement's been
fighting for this for years and look if
if if it's something that bothers you
the way the system's designed you can go
out and do something about it it may
just take a little bit and you and you
got you were inspired to write this
after you were traveling abroad with the
president yeah yeah it was it was in the
midst of all that that i'm sitting in
europe thinking yeah you know
it is our system that's right
and it is ours and if we can keep it for
sure